on the front lines in Ukraine the
life-saving value of armored vehicles
made clear
a Russian mind strike on Ukrainian
troops with no injuries or deaths in a
war that has seen heavy Munitions and
mind strikes kill many the protection
offered by armored vehicles is in high
demand Canada has stepped up by pledging
39 armored vehicles manufactured by
General Dynamics land systems Canada and
another eight armored personnel carriers
from ontario-based Rochelle defense
minister Anita Anand says the government
wants to become a leader in nato in
providing vehicles to Ukraine an angle
the Canadian government has also been
pumping behind closed doors with allies
but how realistic is that promise
armored vehicles land vehicles are a key
focus of the defense industrial base in
Canada and think so it's no accident
that that's what one of the things we
ended up sending to Ukraine Perry said
armored vehicles are a logical choice
for Canada but with an important caveat
the government would have to act quickly
and make significant investments in
order to deliver on the promise there's
no timeline no context Mark Popov who
led armored combat teams in Afghan says
he's dubious the minister can make good
on her statements Canada simply does not
have the ability to manufacture Mass
amounts of armored vehicles and become a
world leader in this compared to our
only Auto allies Canada would likely
need other countries to set aside their
National interest in defense contractors
and agree to buy Canadian instead it's
not clear if that will happen and the
Canadian government would need to commit
a lot more than a few dozen vehicles to
help Ukraine that requires sort of
policy follow through and a constant
provision and and thus far that's not
been
that's not they haven't shown a great
tracker record of that there is however
a Twist in all of this while funding for
armored vehicles plays well in boat Rich
ridings where they're manufactured in
Canada it could also delay how quickly
the Canadian Army gets its own equipment
Donna Mercedes thanks